ya sean escudos metálicos hechos a mano
con la palabra people o palos de bambú
paraguas jugos de basura llenos de
ladrillos estas improvisadas barricadas
callejeras para impedir el avance de las
fuerzas de seguridad están repartidas
por todo mianmar en rangún miles de
manifestantes a favor de la democracia
siguieron en las calles a pesar de la
intensificación de la represión por
parte de las fuerzas militares cuando se
va a cumplir un mes del golpe de
estado-militar la policía elevó la
represión recurriendo a tácticas más
violentas mientras los militares
intentan disolver las protestas en todo
el país pese al uso de la fuerza letal y
las detenciones masivas los
manifestantes y hermanos dicen que no
las disuadirá nos enfrentamos a muchas
medidas represivas en todo el país pero
aún así la gente salió a protestar de
nuevo sin miedo incluso los guardias
forestales se están uniendo al
movimiento y la junta está actuando
ilegalmente por lo que los ciudadanos
deben protegerse
un desafío en números que también se vio
a prueba durante los disturbios en dawei
los medios locales de la ciudad sureña
informaron de que tres manifestantes
murieron por disparos de munición real y
otros fueron heridos con balas de goma
la última jornada de protestas deja al
menos siete muertos en todo el país los
ciudadanos birmanos se han organizado
contra el golpe militar del 1 de febrero
pidiendo la vuelta a la democracia y la
liberación de la líder gubernamental
detenida ansa en sushi